how is it jumping on Tick Tock and
trying to understand that platform from
scratch yeah so from being a successful
YouTuber to understand a totally
different algorithm fundamentally
different algorithm it's interesting
well not even just the algorithm just
the content like I'm going from
basically 15 minute short films so one
sub one minute vertical content at least
a whole different just ballpark
um and so the first little while is
doing Tick Tock it was just kind of
figuring out how what what does Mr Beast
look like in this short form content but
recently we've really started to catch
our stride and come up with some
original Concepts and figure out how to
innovate over there just like we did on
YouTube because I don't want it I didn't
want it to just be shitty YouTube videos
yeah you know and so like an example is
um we played the rock for 100k and rock
paper scissors and the loser had to
donate 100K charity we did um we went to
random people on a campus and we offered
them so I said I'll give you a hundred
dollars if you fly to Paris and give me
a baguette and then they said no and I
was like I'll give you 300 dollars if
you fly repairs give me a big hat and I
was expecting this person to say no and
it go up to like 10 grand he's like yes
and so he flew to Paris got a baguette
and brought it back and gave it to me
and that across everything got like 450
million views and because it's just
really cool just to see this random guy
get on a plane spend a day in Paris and
we cut it up real nicely and bring it
back and so we're starting to find just
tons of original content over there but
it seems like an epic video to make for
one minute exactly no one on short form
is doing it that's the thing it's like
it's just so funny because like tick
tock's been big for a while now years
and then um you know as as we started to
really figure out things on the YouTube
channel and get a cranking where I have
some free time we we set our sights on
Tick Tock and like okay what what are
people not doing how do we make it
better put in more effort make it good
and we did the same thing we did at
YouTube just different over on Tick Tock
and it worked and now we're the fastest
growing or most followed Tick Tock
account in 2022 and it's just funny that
no one else did that and you're not
afraid to do epic stuff which also
during the brainstorming some some of
the ideas you're like that's better as a
short that's crazy yeah can you remember
one because I remember I said that a
bunch but I can't think of what all I
remember is that they were like epic
videos
like really you're going to do that for
a one minute video yeah that's crazy so
like are you posting similar content to
a YouTube short as a tick tock yeah
those would just double up it's just
hard you know what's actually pretty
fascinating and people who do social
media listings this will probably find
this pretty interesting is a picture of
like the content creation meta three
years ago versus now where you can make
sub one minute vertical content and it
go viral on Tick Tock and go viral on
YouTube shorts go viral on Instagram
reels it goes viral on Facebook it goes
Reddit you know you swipe through
vertical content now and Twitter when
you click on a video and you flip
through it so this is actually very
weird this is the first time in the
history of I guess Western social media
that one form of content can actually go
super viral on every single platform
it's never been like that before so
they're going viral individual they're
not like like whatever I can post
something on Tick Tock they'll get 100
million views and then post it on shorts
and it'll get 200 million views and then
post it on Instagram and I get 50
million views and then you know I
haven't yet but you know you can then
turn around and tweet it and get tens of
millions of views and you can post on
Reddit get tons of interviews and and
Facebook and get tens of millions of
views and that that just wasn't a thing
three years ago Twitter didn't have when
because a lot of you probably don't even
know this but when you tap on a video
now and you swipe down it just turns
into Tick Tock that wasn't a thing even
a year ago read it that wasn't a thing a
year ago probably two years ago that
wasn't a thing on Instagram three years
ago that wasn't a thing on YouTube right
with YouTube shorts so this is all new
and uh I don't it's weird I haven't
heard a single person talk about it but
this is the first time where content can
actually go viral on every single
platform and you don't have to write or
film a video for Facebook film that 12
minute video for YouTube film a sub 60
second video for tick tock write a tweet
for Twitter and post this on Reddit you
can just do the same thing on every
platform and the fact that your content
has gone viral on multiple platforms
regularly means that
virality is not accidental
sometimes it can be of course but it's
it's just it can be engineered it's yeah
so many people say it's luck and they're
like you're just lucky or this or that
but what what are we up to probably like
a thousand videos over 10 million views
like we don't ever have a dud like you
can call it luck but I think it could be
trained I I counsel YouTubers all the
time and show them how to go from
getting a couple million views a month
to 10 million views a month very easily
if I'm even certain ones like
just one of my friends like he was just
really struggling and so I just started
showing him basically everything I know
and just doing like once every week
sometimes once every two weeks calls and
it went from ten thousand dollars a
month on YouTube to over 400 000. just
doing these little counseling calls and
so I mean people can make excuses all
they want and say it's just luck or say
you know
um well anyways I don't even want to
quote all the other stuff but it's just
it is it is a teachable skill it's a
learnable skill you can study your way
to consistently make viral videos no
matter how small your channel is even if
you have zero subscribers you could if
if you actually studied hard enough and
like basically if you knew what I knew
and some of these so I don't sound so
arrogant also like some of these other
friends that have that I'd say are the
smartest people in the world when it
comes to content creation online if you
had the knowledge that was in our heads
you could do it very easily I see people
do it all the time
um and what's even more interesting is I
go on podcasts and I say everything I
know and these people are also very open
some of them I know it's all out there
and a lot of people instead of just
studying that and trying to absorb and
apply it in their own way they're just
like no it's just luck you know so you
do lay it all out there but I got to
push back to one interesting thing I I
think a crucial component of your
success is the idea stage the idea
generation the brainstorm I heard today
but getting really good at generating
ideas is so it's not it's not just
the uh the selection of the thumbnail
and the title that creative process it's
also just the the engine of generating
really good ideas of course and getting
that I mean I I would say that is
probably the thing that needs to be
trained the most for most creators right
that they're they just don't put enough
ideas on paper yes but also a lot of
creators also just don't
you know which I didn't either for the
longest time just didn't don't make good
enough content you know content that's
worthy of getting 10 million views in
the idea or the execution of the idea
both I mean like think about how many
people just make videos they film in
under 20 minutes and they don't really
put any effort into it and like you know
it's like my first 500 videos didn't
deserve to get a million views like
there's a reason they did they're
terrible you know but at the time I
thought they did right and I'm in the
mindset of a lot of small YouTubers or I
thought those videos deserved a million
views and I thought that algorithm pay
to me but I watched them back now and I
can tell you exactly why the videos are
[ __ ] horrible you know what I mean
well so what was the Breakthrough for
you to start realizing to start having a
self-awareness you know about these
videos aren't good enough you're
probably still going through that you're
probably still growing to see like yeah
every six months you should look back
and hate your videos or at least see
things you could improve and be like oh
I could have done this better that
better if not then you're not learning
quick enough in my opinion at least
where's the source of that learning even
for you now uh just look at it I just
got back from them I mean I just got
back from a mastermind where I just got
like you know 10 of the smartest people
I knew and we just locked ourselves in a
cabin and taught each other stuff
constantly every day not every day now
probably every other day I go on a walk
and I just call random people I'll just
say teach me something and uh I mean
it's just uh you just have to have a
never-ending thirst for learning like
that's very imperative especially if you
want like if you want to get on top and
then stay on top the only way to do it
is just to constantly be learning or
someone who is learning is just gonna
you know have a leg up on you in the
knowledge game and what kind of stuff
are you because you you've talked about
Offline that you just love learning of
all kinds it doesn't matter but in terms
of videos are you studying videos are
you studying recently not as much I'm
more because to get to the videos I want
I have to build this business and scale
up and hire so one of my recent time has
been like my teenage years were spent
studying virality and studying content
creation Now I'm studying how to build a
Content company so I can actually
produce the crazy ideas I want to
produce if that makes any sense